ANGLE.
♪ ♪
IS HER CABLE COMPETITORS ARE
DEVOTING HOURS OF COVERAGE TODAY
TO THE PRESIDENT'S TWEETS
ABOUT STORMY DANIELS, VOTERS I
THINK ARE TUNING HIM OUT.
WHY?
BECAUSE THE VOTERS ARE SMARTER
THAN THE MEDIA THINKS THEY ARE,
AS USUAL.
AMERICANS OUTSIDE THE LEFTIST
ACTIVIST BUBBLE ARE FOCUSING ON
ISSUES THAT ACTUALLY AFFECT
THEIR DAILY LIVES.
POCKETBOOK ISSUES.
THE STOCK MARKET JUMPED 500
POINTS TODAY, THAT IS GOOD FOR
YOUR 401(K).
THE LABOR DEPARTMENT REPORTED
THAT THERE ARE 7 MILLION JOB
OPENINGS CURRENTLY IN THE
UNITED STATES.
OUR INDUSTRIAL OUTPUT IS SURGING
THEM ALL FANTASTIC NEWS.
AMERICANS ALSO SEE SOME TROUBLE
ON THE HORIZON AS WELL.
LAWLESSNESS AT THE BORDER, NO
SOCIETY SHOULD TOLERATE.
WE HAVE ANOTHER MASS OF PEOPLE,
AS MANY AS 4,000 I AM TOLD.
ANOTHER SO-CALLED MIGRANT
CARAVAN MAKING ITS WAY FROM
HONDURAS TO THE UNITED STATES.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS HAD JUST
ABOUT ENOUGH.
>> WE HAVE THE DUMBEST
IMMIGRATION LAWS IN THE WORLD.
THE WORLD LAUGHS AT US, BUT WE
ARE GETTING THEM CHANGED.
WE NEED SOME MORE REPUBLICANS.
>> Laura: I WILL SAY.
FOR MANY YEARS VOTERS HAVE BEEN
TELLING POLITICIANS, ENFORCE THE
BORDER AND CLOSE IMMIGRATION
LOOPHOLES.
IN FACT EVEN ON THE ISSUE OF
LEGAL IMMIGRATION, A LOT OF
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW THIS, THE
COUNTRY IS NOT CLAMORING FOR BIG
INCREASES.
CHECK THIS OUT.
ONLY 28% OF AMERICANS WANT
IMMIGRATION LEVELS INCREASED.
29% OF AMERICANS WANT THEM
DECREASED.
OF COURSE MOST POLITICIANS
CONTINUE TO JUST IGNORE THE
WISHES OF THE PEOPLE, SO WHAT
THEY DO IS CONTINUE TO EXPAND
THINGS LIKE DISTANT RELATIVE
CHAIN MIGRATION.
THEY REFUSE TO ALLOCATE MONEY TO
THE BUILDING OF THE ENTIRE WALL
OF THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
THEY REFUSE TO PASS LEGISLATION
TO ALLOW FOR IMMEDIATE BORDER
TURN BACKS OF ANYONE CROSSING
THE BORDER ILLEGALLY.
AND OF COURSE, DEMOCRATS ARE
AGAINST ALL RULES.
DONALD TRUMP WON THE PRESIDENCY
IN LARGE PART BECAUSE HE
WOULDN'T EXPECT THE STATUS QUO
ON IMMIGRATION.
AS USUAL, HE WAS FIVE
STEPS AHEAD OF MOST EVERY
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN ON THE
ISSUE.
IN JULY THEY FOUND THAT
AMERICANS IDENTIFIED IMMIGRATION
HAS THE TOP ISSUE FOR THEM GOING
INTO THE MIDTERMS.
LAST MONTH IT WAS THE SECOND
MOST IMPORTANT ISSUE TIED WITH
JUST GENERAL ECONOMIC PROBLEMS.
DEMOCRATS THOUGHT THAT A FOCUS
ON THE TYPICAL ISSUE OF CHILD
SEPARATION, A PRACTICE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS NOW ENDED,
THAT THAT WOULD TURN OUT TO
VOTERS AND GET DEMOCRATS OR
LATINO VOTERS REALLY EXCITED TO
GET OUT THERE.
I DON'T THINK IT IS WORKING FOR
THEM.
REMEMBER BACK IN 2016, AT THE
LATINO VOTER TURNOUT DID NOT
INCREASE.
DESPITE TRUMP'S PUSH FOR THE
WALL AND A LOT OF STRONGER
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT.
OF COURSE HISPANIC AMERICANS ARE
THEMSELVES DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED BY THE IMPACT OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION, AND THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
DITTO FOR BLACK AMERICANS.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT AS THE
SECOND CARAVAN DRAMA UNFOLDS, IT
TURNS OUT THAT SOME
ESTABLISHMENT REPUBLICANS ARE
WAKING UP TO THE WISDOM OF
TRUMP.
>> IT MAKES THE IMMIGRATION
DEBATE MORE ON TRUMP'S TERMS.
THERE IS NO RIGHT TO COME TO
AMERICA.
WE CAN HAVE RULES OF WHO COMES.
WHERE IS MEXICO?
THEY NEED TO HELP US.
LAST TIME I CHECKED YOU JUST
CAN'T WALK FROM GUATEMALA TO
HEAR WITHOUT GOING TO MEXICO.
>> Laura: OH, YES, THE
PRESIDENT WARNED THE PRESIDENT
OF HONDURAS COME WITH THE LARGE
CARAVAN HEADS INTO THE U.S. AND
DOES NOT STOP, HE WILL CUT OFF
FOREIGN AID.
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE HAS WARNED
THEM ABOUT HONDURAS, GUATEMALA
AND EL SALVADOR TO TELL THEIR
PEOPLE DO NOT MAKE THE DANGEROUS
TREK TO AMERICA.
THE U.S. WILL NOT TOLERATE THIS
BLATANT DISREGARD FOR OUR BORDER
AND SOVEREIGNTY.
BY THE WAY, HONDURAS IS ON TRACK
TO RECEIVE $65.7 MILLION IN
FOREIGN AID FROM THE U.S. IN THE
UPCOMING FISCAL YEAR, 2019.
BACK TO THE MIDTERMS.
AS FRUSTRATED AS SO MANY AS LSR,
THE CAUSE MAY BE TOTALLY LOST IF
THE OPEN BORDER DEMOCRATS TAKE
THE HOUSE
WHILE THE PRESIDENT IS FOCUSED
ON IMPORTANT THINGS LIKE
ABOLISHING THE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION GANGS COME MS-13,
DEMOCRATS WANT TO ABOLISH I.C.E.
>> WE NEED TO REBUILD OUR
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM FROM TOP TO
BOTTOM.
STARTING BY REPLACING I.C.E WITH
SOMETHING THAT REFLECTS OUR
MORALITY.
>> WE CAN REPLACE IT AND WE CAN
REPLACE IT WITH A HUMANE AGENCY
THAT IS DIRECTED TOWARDS SAFE
PASSAGE.
>> Laura: SAFE PASSAGE?
EVERYBODY COME ON IN.
THEY ARE NOT ALONE OF COURSE.
THERE ARE A LOT MORE LIKE THEM
THAT BELIEVE THE SAME THING.
AGAIN, THEY COULD NOT BE CLEAR
FOR THE MIDTERM VOTERS.
THERE SO MUCH ON THE LINE FOR
AMERICA.
WE'LL TRUMP GET THE FUNDING FOR
HIS WALL?
WILL THE MASS MIGRATION OF OTHER
COUNTRIES IN CENTRAL AMERICA WE
STOPPED AT ALL?
EVER!
WILL TRAVESTY SUCH AS BIRTHRIGHT
CITIZENSHIP FINALLY BE ENDED?
WILL WE MANDATE TO PENALIZE
BUSINESSES WHO GAIN THE SYSTEM
TO KEEP AMERICAN WAGES LOW?
OF THIS MY FRIENDS YOU CAN BE
SURE, YOUR VIEWS ON IMMIGRATION
WILL HAVE ZERO IMPACT AND ZERO
INFLUENCE ON A HOUSE DOMINATED
BY DEMOCRATS WHO WANT TO REPLACE
YOU, THE AMERICAN VOTERS, WITH
NEWLY AMNESTY TO CITIZENS.
AN EVER INCREASING NUMBER OF
MIGRANTS.
IF REPUBLICANS CHOOSE TO UNITE
BEHIND THE PRESIDENTS
IMMIGRATION POLICY, THE WAY THEY
JUST DID IN THE KAVANAUGH FIGHT.